[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on programmed
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the Superstar of Alternative
Health and purveyor of medical truth Dr
Joel Wallach
[Music]
hello and welcome to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie Dr Joel Wallach your host a
veterinarian and physician and I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to die it's 75.5 like
their parents and grandparents I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to be sick and miserable
for the last 10 to 15 years of their
life like the parents and grandparents
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free one Triple Eight three seven
nine two five five two again that's
toll-free one Triple Eight three seven
nine two five five two don't forget my
website
www.brjwallet.com
www.drjwalek.com and don't forget
you know the prices of all my books and
CDs and DVDs will be going up in a
couple weeks and so if you've been
pondering about wanting to buy books and
CDs and DVDs now is the time to do it so
you get the current prices and don't
forget if you buy 10 of any one title of
my books guess what you get a huge
discount and so you know those are all
the things you can work with here but
you figure within uh two to three weeks
we're going to be going with the new
prices because the printing now is
exceedingly High compared to what it was
three years ago five years ago and ten
years ago
okay well this is Veterans Day and I
want to thank all the veterans of every
Branch to the service you know the Army
the Marines uh Navy Air Force and I I
spent um seven years uh in the Army
attached to a Fort Leonard Wood in
Central Missouri uh our tool was the 105
and 155 house there was a
um field artillery
and traveled around quite a bit with
them and then went on into the Air Force
and
um they put me into
first aid stations in battle groups the
first aid stations okay because of my
training and everything
and so it's one of those things where uh
spent over 20 years and I really really
loved uh doing the things we did in the
Army and it did in the Air Force our
goal was to help America and help the
world and we I thought we did a great
job
and um so I want to thank all the
veterans of every again
every
military especially and then
um if if you have some time if you're
retired now
okay now even if you haven't retired but
if you have retired
um we're looking for help we're going
like crazy we need people who have the
training and the passion and the
responsibility
um in their hearts uh for America uh
like the veterans and so you might want
to contact us again at Triple Eight
three seven nine two five five two
that's Triple Eight three seven nine two
five five two or you can go to my
website and see what's going on we'll
find somebody in your area to coach you
and and so forth so www.drjwallet.com
and what we do is we help people with
their health we help them
um get off of a prescription medication
we help them
rebuild their tissues we don't want
people to have legs amputated we don't
want people to have double knee
Replacements and double ear Replacements
we don't want people to have open heart
surgeries and ablations and all this
kind of stuff because guess what in most
cases I'd say 99.9 of the time that's
about most cases these are nutritional
deficiencies these are not genetic
issues they're not autoimmune issues and
by giving individual the nutrients and
keeping away from the bad foods and
maximize absorption and reduce or
eliminate inflammation
and rebuild every tissue in the body I
don't care if it's the brain the spinal
cord the lungs the heart the liver of
the kidneys uh bone marrow that's an
important one bone marrow white blood
cells antibodies red blood cells
platelets all made in the bone marrow
most people will never see their bone
marrow most people don't even ever think
about their bone marrow okay that's very
important and so this is the realm we
deal in we have programs for 600
different uh health issues and diseases
we have 5 000 products and some of these
things are so what should I say right
now so important because of so many
people being laid off businesses closing
um the pandemic is going crazy
and it's one of those things where we
just have to say okay it's time we
engage our veterans
and get them to employ their past their
passion and their knowledge and their
experience once more to help America and
so we're so excited about that and then
people say where'd you get that Dead
Doctors Don't Like thing well when I was
going around and building our youngevity
business and lecturing all over the
world I was handing out
printed obituaries of metal doctors that
were in the medical journal that would
just copy the obituaries and medical
journals and hand out the obituaries of
doctors who died at 35 and 40 and 50.
and they just had a heart disease and
they died of lung disease they died of
brain disease they died of all kinds of
stuff gastrointestinal diseases it had
cancer stroke and diabetes I would
pressure like everybody else and it just
didn't make sense to people
why I was you know using them and
handing out the obituaries saying well
hey you know you can do a better job
than these doctors are doing
what I say and you can add 25 to 50
Health years your life do it they say
you know they may reduce your symptoms a
little bit guess what you're still going
to die 25 to 50 years early
and so people said well
why is it you you keep running all these
things about doctor's deaths
and then I said I don't know where it
came from just popped out of my mouth
Dead Doctors Don't Lie and it became the
title of my CDs okay and my audio
cassettes before the books came out we
sold 40 million
audio cassettes entitled dead Doctor
still alive 40 million copies all over
the world it's in nine languages
um and so this is very well known stuff
only you hand out your card and it has
you know representative for uh
youngevity a representative for Dead
Doctors Don't Lie well
say okay sit down tell me about it we'll
be back after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs radio network with your
host Dr Joel Wallach if you've got
questions for Dr Wally call us weekdays
between noon and 1 pm Pacific time at
831-685-1080 toll free
888-379-2552 call throughout the hours
we do have lines that open up
[Music]
aromatherapy oils have been prized by
ancient cultures for thousands of years
youngevity's ancient Legacy true
aromatherapy is no exception essential
oils are The Fragrant life Essence from
plants that are gently removed through
the process of steam distillation
youngevity's age at Legacy essential
oils are of the purest concentrations
from the most respected and ethical
distillers worldwide midi ancient Legacy
oils come directly from families in the
East which have been distilling
essential oils for over 100 years keep
ancient legacy's tea tree oil in your
medicine chest for first aid tea tree
oil is great for soothing the itching
and stinging associated with insect
bites Burns scrapes and other skin
irritations it's also effective as an
antiseptic to learn more about
aromatherapy and essential oils contact
your local youngevity associate today
and don't forget to ask about business
opportunities if your doctor is telling
you that you can get all the nutrients
you need to stay healthy well that's
just wrong Dr Joel Wallach has
identified 90 essential nutrients that
the human body needs to thrive crops
only need three nutrients to thrive so
where does your doctor think the other
87 nutrients come from they don't so if
you're not supplementing you're starving
your body youngevity's Beyond Tangy
Tangerine will get you a long way down
the road to getting those 90 essential
nutrients Beyond Tangy Tangerine
contains plant-derived minerals combined
with vitamins amino acids and other
beneficial nutrients Beyond Tangy
Tangerine is a balanced and complete
daily supplement so if you want to give
your body the nutrients it needs order
Beyond Tangy Tangerine today contact
your local youngevity associate to order
this product and don't forget to ask
about home-based business opportunities
foreign
[Music]
Doctors Don't Lie in the CBS radio
network Dr Joel wallacher of young Judy
and I accepted to say we do have lines
open give us a call toll free one Triple
Eight three seven nine two five five two
again that's toll-free one Triple Eight
three seven nine two five five two don't
forget my website
www.brj wallet.com
www.drjwalek.com and don't forget
again the
um you know four books in one ten CD set
at the printers now they're gonna be
coming out here pretty soon and so the
prices for books and CDs and DVDs are
going to be going up within say two or
three weeks and if you ever pondered by
some of these things don't forget if you
buy 10 of any one title of the books you
get a big discount and if you um
if you go ahead and you you use the
um you know you use the the prices we
have now you'll save an enormous amount
of money okay because the prices are
going to go up it may be in some cases
18 some cases 25 percent because if the
prices of printing is just outrageously
gone up okay so what what can I say it's
just reality at times
and and so what you know we've been
talking about this for a while this is
something we can't get away from and
that is
um when you look at the problems we have
most of them are self-inflicted and for
instance uh the diseases
uh that are caused by eating improperly
are let's see here highly pressure
diabetes we're talking about
um arthritis we're talking about back
problems we're talking about Alzheimer's
disease uh
we're talking about all these things
okay uh let's see anemia all right all
this stuff
and basically if everybody were to just
do some simple things number one stay
away from the bad stuff no fried foods
get rid of all the inflammation from
fried foods you know then you want to
stay away from uh let's see here and
stay away from things like processed
meats and we're talking about ham and
bacon and bologna and salami uh we're
talking about sausage those kind of
things because they have chemicals in
them I'm going to stay away from oils
cooking oils salad dressings those kind
of things they oxidize things and turn
them into cancer causing substances
and then you also want to stay away from
gluten a wheat nobody Ryan oats no
gluten and also you want to stay away
from buckwheat okay because buckwheat
contains a substance called phagopyries
which is very very bad it inflames your
arteries and veins and capillaries and
planes all your major organs and glands
and so forth it's one of those things
where doctors want to believe that
these sorts of things are autoimmune
okay lupus
erythema is not autoimmune it's just a
very simple nutritional deficiency
disease caused by malabsorption because
people were eating all the bad foods and
not supplementing that's a bad
combination all right and then you want
to see here
um I I had Tourette Syndrome which is
kind of a lupus kind of thing uh
Tourette Syndrome also goes along with
MS and Guillain-Barre syndrome I had
Tourette Syndrome for five years I
figured out when I was nine twenty
doctors couldn't figure it out 20
doctors couldn't figure out I figured it
out cured it in three days by getting
rid of all the bad foods and taking the
90 essential nutrients I don't know how
to make any clearer than that and then
don't forget fibromyalgia as again
nutritional deficiencies which are
thrives nutritional deficiencies the
secondary infection of a bug called
mycoplasma which is killable with an
antibody called menocycle so you take
our healthy Bone and Joint pack and get
a prescription for the amino cycling I
don't care if you've had rheumatoid
arthritis for 40 years you can get rid
of it in weeks you know bowel syndrome
again this is due to consumption of
gluten wheat bread around oats and
buckwheat they go pyrant okay and if
you're eating both of those your
irritable bowel syndrome is going to
really really really be bad okay Crohn's
disease is a kind of a reduced
um when you say symptoms of irritable
bowel syndrome celiac disease same thing
reduced uh symptoms of irritable bowel
syndrome diverticulitis same thing
metabolic syndrome is obesity diabetes
and high blood pressure all three of
those are due to nutritional
deficiencies even obesity is due to
nutritional deficiency not calorie
deficiencies but nutritional
deficiencies causing a behavior called
Pica which has you eating 8 10 12 15 20
meals a day instead of three meals a day
okay
we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie
on the zbs radio network with your host
Dr Joel Wallach if you'd like to talk to
Dr Wallach have questions for him you
can call us weekdays between noon and 1
pm Pacific time at
831-685-1080 toll-free
888-379-2552 call throughout the hours
we do have lines that open up
foreign
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself youngevities Beyond Tangy
Tangerine a blend of plant-derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat or Yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and its
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
Nutra crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild
youngevity's Beyond Tangy Tangerine is
available in one pound canisters and
also in 30 count on the go stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product and don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity hello Judy devilbus here if
I could only afford to get one product
out of everything that product would be
the ultimate classic it has the vitamins
the minerals the bioflavonoids it even
has grape seed extract the one product
that would give you just about
everything under the sun you would need
for a perfect nutritional program would
be the ultimate classic by the way
people that are on the go it's very very
hard to take the liquids with them when
they go on their trip to get their
supplements in every day well you know
something you can use the ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules when
I'm going on a trip if I have enough
room I just take the two bottles with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple it's very easy there's no
mess no fuss no Refrigeration just take
your capsules take your tablets and your
finish for the day to order these
products call your local youngevity
distributor today
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call down to change your
life that's 313-444-3463
[Music]
foreign.com
www.drjy.com get a hold of my books and
CDs and DVDs remember the price will be
going up here in a couple of weeks
because the the new batch that was
printed is at the current prices and the
um if you buy the books and see the DVDs
now you'll pay the old prices you'll
save quite a bit of money so I urge you
to consider that okay Germania there yes
I'm here yes okay now you know you come
from a military family right yep my dad
was in the second world war he was in
the invasion of Normandy yes
well there you go and so we appreciate
that and so
um what what is it that you think that
we can do
um to utilize the the experiences and
the talent and the training of military
uh veterans to help people today with
their health problems I mean things are
going crazy right now and um in his last
election is showing how bizarre things
are
according to you know who's doing what
and so forth and so people are going to
have to start you know doing more of
their own health care themselves and so
how do you think a military background a
military experience plays into this
personally I don't think it does because
I think that people that are in the
military are basically programmed to
obey the government and they have to get
vaccinated without question and they
just accept that and once you sign up in
the military I know a very dear person
that was killed with that Agent Orange
in the Vietnam War
and yeah I just found out
okay that's not the question I'm asking
well I questioned the government because
all these wars were starting over
patterned pocketbooks for the rich and
you know that
so that's my opinion and I'm not going
to change it
well you do you have earned the right to
have your opinion uh and that is my
opinion and I have a right under the
Constitution to
there you go now that you've done that
I'm going to ask you the question again
because I didn't ask you if your for
your opinion on that subject when he
said well people who have military
training okay
um what is it about the military
training it would allow somebody to have
and build a successful helpful uh
youngevity organizations
well maybe dealing with people and stuff
yeah I mean when you're in the military
you learn to have to learn to deal with
a lot of different people depending on
what type of the military you're in
what I'm looking for is discipline
disciplined disciplined to avoid the bad
things discipline to do all the good
stuff discipline to say okay I'm going
to help 10 people a month 10 new people
a month okay and this is discipline we
make a plan and you work to plan and I
think people with a military experience
have experience with discipline and
there's all kinds of other stuff that
you point out that are certainly factual
and have I would say impact on the
individual but somebody who has
experience in the military even if it's
only for a year or two
they have
the understanding of discipline and that
helps them help other people
so thank you very much my dear and we'll
be back after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie
on the zbs radio network with your host
Dr Joel Wallach if you'd like to talk to
Dr Wallach call us weekdays
between noon and 1 pm Pacific time at
831-685-1080 toll-free
888-379-2552 call throughout the hours
we do have lines at open open up
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number 313-44-30
463 that's
313-444-3463 call down to change your
life that's
313-444-3463 hi this is Dr Joel Wallach
your host of Dead Doctors Don't Lie if
you're interested in a colon cleanse
blood cleanse liver cleanse you know in
the classical herbal way you want to ask
your youngevity associate for Herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that in
your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest I guarantee it it will
give you a cleanse you can control the
dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy nothing
better than a happy colon herbal
rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about on the Dead Doctors
Don't Lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities
greetings everyone Judy devilba's here
what do you think of when you hear the
words Tangy Tangerine well I think of
like a sweet Tangy tasting something
well what I'm referring to is the
ultimate Tangy Tangerine it's a
fantastic product it has everything you
need and a great benefit is it's very
very delicious it's very easy to drink
I've suggested it even to youngsters
even children like it even little guys
even little girls they come right into
my office their parents can't get them
to take those chewables and besides that
they're not as good as tangy tangerine
and I give them a little taste of that
and you know something they're pleased
as punch so if it's good for a child and
it tastes delicious why not you there's
no excuse not to take a vitamin when it
tastes as good as that does so how about
it Tangy Tangerine should be the answer
to all of your nutritional program
problems for more information or to
order call your youngevity distributor
today and don't forget to ask about
youngevity home-based business
opportunities
this is the zbs radio network network
network
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't Lie
on the zds radio network Dr Joel wallet
care of young Duty 95 Crusade we do have
lines open give us a call toll free one
Triple Eight three seven nine two five
five two don't forget our website
www.drjwallen.com and don't forget right
now if you buy the books and CDs and
DVDs are getting the current prices in
two or three weeks they're going to be
going up by I don't know 10 15 25
depending on the book of the CD and it's
one of those things where
um poor Warren is forearmed
okay let's see here uh Doug let's go to
callers let's head to Santa Cruz
California and Beth you're on with Dr
Wallach
you're on the air how can we help you hi
well I called you
um about a month ago and we got the hair
analysis
I don't know where to begin with what
information to give to you about my son
um
and we got the hair analysis it
recommends different supplements I have
no idea where to get them or okay well
that's that's the laboratory is it
that's not our stuff okay that's not our
stuff I apologize for that okay that
that list should not have been sent to
you okay okay okay yeah you want to get
our stuff right because their stuff
isn't
is okay is it on the same plane as ours
now uh what's your son's issue again
I've talked to a thousand people since
since I apologize I remember
he has I don't know where to begin he's
had the lifelong issue ever since he was
two and a half months and got his first
DPT shot in 1974.
so he'll be 48 this year
um recently learned that the baby shots
he had gave him seat uh Strokes that
gave him seizures but he is a terrific
athlete
um it was after his like with each shot
things got worse and when he was five
years old he got a DPT shot
I guess it was 1979 and after that his
he had his first Grandma seizure the
others were focal point and the left
side of his face drooped and it's not
really so noticeable anymore
but anyways fast forward he had Lyme
disease in high school he had
exposure to mold in 2006.
where he emptied out an ice chest that
had all this feathery mold from moldy
feathers with spores from a cantaloupe
and ever since then he's been real
sensitive to molds and we found out in
um that he had the worst case of sleep
apnea obstructive and Central where he
doesn't always take a breath at night
so what's happening now is
his um when he doesn't he has a machine
an ASB machine but when it comes out of
place or this lodged and he doesn't take
the breath and I guess his oxygen goes
low he has like a sleep disorder a
seizure and it sets off like two and a
half weeks of nighttime and daytime
seizures and that's why we're calling
you to see if there's something to help
okay okay okay let's stop there now let
me ask you a couple of quick questions
here because you can how old is he now
you say he's 48.
yes
okay does he complain about ringing his
ears
no
okay uh do you have any idea how many
times he wakes up to ninth year and
eight once three times five times ten
times
um I would say at least three times
okay
and he had Bell's Palsy when he had one
side of his face group okay this is the
seventh cranial nerve being squeezed
okay by the by the skull and uh getting
up three times 90 or an eight uh that's
the skull squeezing the spinal cord and
the spinal cord is telling the urinary
bladder to urinate okay so hang on we'll
come back and Sean I will give you a
program for your son
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs radio network with your
host Dr Joel Wallach if you've got
questions for Dr Wallach call us
weekdays between noon and 1pm Pacific
time at 831-685-1080
toll-free
888-379-2552 call throughout the hours
we do have lines that open up
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-44-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-44-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's three one three four four
four thirty four sixty three I am Judy
devilbus here I am speaking to you again
I just wanted to tell you that recently
I started drinking the way shakes again
the chocolate way shake and you need to
remember the way Shake isn't just for
losing weight it's a fantastic place to
get your great protein and if you're
trying to gain weight you can take it
along with your meals and the best part
is if you want to just have a great
protein shake do like I do put it over
ice Stir It Up and you can sip on it for
20 minutes to an hour I do it every
single day I absolutely love it you need
to get back to it too it's really good
for you and it makes not fat but it
makes muscle after you work out and you
can also mix it up in a blender with an
egg and you have the most incredible
Health protein shake or mix it with a
little water Stir It Up and you have a
little pudding and who doesn't like
pudding for more information or to order
call your youngevity distributor today
and don't forget to ask about Young
jevity home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't Lie
on the zds radio network Dr Joel Wallach
or young Duty 95 Crusade and let's see
here Charmaine are you there
yes
okay what are we going to do to help
Beth with her son who's having seizures
she's got stuff going on in his hands
he's getting up three times a night to
urinate he's had Bell's Palsy once had
his face troops and he has sleep issues
I believe he's got osteoporosis of his
goal and he's um and you know he's got
stuff going on Downstream in his back
and his joints and stuff like that sleep
issues and so on so what would you do
for him he's 48 years old
and we didn't get a weight uh how much
how much did your son weigh Beth about
160 and he's five foot eight
okay all right so 160 pound chairman
what would you do for best son
I would uh first of all we need to get
him on a gluten-free diet that's
important no wheat barley Rye or oats no
fried foods no burnt animal fat no oils
no uh
[Music]
peanuts and no buckwheat anyway uh then
I would get him on two healthy brain and
hard packs and I'd also add some
colloidal silver to that and I would
personally add some oxybody cherry berry
and because he's got mold problems he
needs to clean all that stuff out and I
would get him on College and peptides
MSM
and uh vitamin D3 for absorption
and uh
he could take about some circulation
stuff yep ultimate daily Classics for
circulation and he needs to get on I
would get him on the synaptic event I'd
also get him on the uh sleep bees for at
night they take the sleep there you go
yeah take the sleepies and also snap if
you're exactly right to three twice a
day two hours a month and call us every
couple of weeks that's because you're
going to see some fast improvements here
okay Doug let's go to callers
let's head to Houston Texas and Jan
you're on with Dr Wallach
oh Jan you're on here
that's Jan you're on the air how can we
help you
yesterday regarding a 29 year old male
who has no problem getting an erection
but he does have premature ejaculation
and you ask him questions that I had to
call him back and get the answers to so
he's 5'5 in height he's approximately
180 pounds
the um he doesn't have any other health
problems no have no high blood pressure
no diabetes no ringing in the ears
he um
he's had one hernia surgery on both
sides and he says at night he wakes up
about once to go to the bathroom
and he says but but he says every time
he drinks even a small amount of liquids
he has to he has to urinate
and um
he doesn't have any balance problems he
played basketball and lift weights
um and he says when he does
um climax he
feels very drained for two to three
hours afterwards okay all right here we
go uh sure what would you do for 180
pound guy he has
um sort of sexual issues
um and um
he has peripheral neuropathies you know
nerve stuff going on and so what would
you do for him
again he's got to get on a gluten-free
diet and um anyway then I would get him
on two healthy branded hard packs and I
would add the Zera test to his stuff
and I would also add the rebound he
needs to take a rebound for energy and
stamina
that will help him
okay
if he takes the cans you've got to pop
the tops on him the night before put
them in the refrigerator so they off gas
the bubbly so they're flat in the
morning if he takes the canister or the
sticks he can you know just make it and
drink it right away but if he's going to
drink it from the cans he's got to pop
the tops and put them in the
refrigerator so that they off gas the
carbonation overnight okay so let's go
there
and then call US every couple of weeks
because you're going to see some fast
improvements don't forget that zero test
um and he needs how many eggs a day
Charmaine a lot that's what I just
wanted to say yeah he needs at least six
eggs a day that's gonna really help them
eggs and butter
scrambled sauce scrambled butter yep
there you go
with all his issues
yeah not hard-boiled not not fried but
just soft soft yolks three twice a day
minimum okay you could have nine if he
wants and um no cholesterol lowering
drugs and so give us a call every couple
of weeks because you're gonna have a
great story okay let's see here do we
have time for another one Doug yeah
let's head to Wisconsin and Kathy you're
on with Dr Wallach
okay Kathy
can we help your service and you're
sharing your expertise I have two quick
questions
um one is for myself one is for my dog
um for me I have eczema and I have a
goiter and I've gained 50 pounds since I
went through menopause I'm 56 years old
I'm 5'6 I'm female I weigh 180 pounds I
currently take the on the go 90 for life
I take an extra EFA I take a selenium
and I take an Ocean's gold what else can
I do
okay when you say you take eight oceans
gold you're taking one a day
yeah I take one yep yep and I take one
extra selenium and I just take the one
one packet of the triangle I just did
start taking two thinking well maybe two
would be better
okay
okay uh first of all I would get a hair
analysis get the book Rare Earth
Ventures go to chapter 10 and 11 page
272 10 and 11. okay
okay
and Page 272 is where it all starts and
I'll tell you how to do everything okay
and then Sherman what would you do for
Kathy here
um she's she's got um a glider and she's
taking one Ocean's goal today
okay well definitely she's under dosing
herself for one thing and the other
thing eczema is basically a gluten
problem so she needs to get on a
gluten-free diet no wheat barley Rye
roast no fried foods no burnt animal fat
no oils no buckwheat and no peanuts and
that's going to help a lot just getting
on that and then because of her weight
she needs two healthy brain and hard
packs not one because of her weight and
I would get her on the collagen peptides
um
and I would get around vitamin D3 for
absorption I'd get around some snapped
of
and uh
Whatever She's Taken I would
if she's taken stuff she likes to take I
would just up it quite a bit because you
got to figure the bottles are made for a
hundred pound person for a month so like
for selenium there's 90 capsules in
there so 100 pound person would take
three a day
so if you weigh closer to 200 pounds you
need six a day right
it's a good way to tell how much you
really need
and so she'll get a lot better results
if she upset also more eggs and butter
will help her
yeah three eggs twice a day I'm gonna
soft scrambling butter or soft poached
thin butter
absolutely not margarine okay dry eggs
won't count in fact they can cause
cancer and also you don't want to
hard-boiled eggs because you've killed
the cholesterol okay you cholesterol is
your best friends here and I'd also have
her take the xerofem through those times
maybe two bottles a month and so let's
uh go there and and the ocean's gold out
here take three of those twice at eight
will be two miles a month or the oceans
the old for her goiter and so you got to
stay away from cat foods you're going to
stay away from the bad foods uh Kathy uh
no wheat run around oats no no uh
buckwheat no buckwheat pancakes no
buckwheat um uh let's see here's some
noodles absolutely no buckwheat cereal
no buckwheat no buckwheat no buckwheat
because people say well if I can't have
gluten I'll just eat buckwheat but then
you're going from bad to worse okay let
me go in that direction
give us a call every couple of weeks
because you're going to have a great
story we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs or radio network with
your host Dr Joel Wallach if you've got
questions for Dr Wallach call us
weekdays between noon and 1 pm Pacific
time at 831
685-1080 toll free 888-379-2552
[Music]
the antioxidants found in many fruits
and vegetables are known to help support
and promote good health research has
also shown that dark chocolate once
known as the food of the Gods is rich in
healthy nutrients in fact dark chocolate
is higher in antioxidant content than
any other food youngevity has combined a
proprietary blend of velvety rich dark
chocolate with whole fruit pulp and
whole fruit juice extracts from
mangosteen Goji or wolf Berry acai berry
and Cherry along with vitamins and
minerals producing a smooth Rich delay
collectible concentrate called
cocogeevity it tastes so great I
sometimes drink it right out of the
bottle or pour it over ice cream
cocogeevity is highly bioavailable
meaning your body will absorb and make
use of all of these healthy nutrients if
you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities if you're the type of
person who likes to volunteer and help
others this should interest you what
better way to help people than to help
them with improved Health youngevity has
been helping people promote Optimal
Health among others for decades our
approach to health is drastically
different than medical doctors who
mostly only treat symptoms as a
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach discovered
that many common disease states are
actually preventable and reversible our
mission is to help people achieve
overall health and wellness and to help
educate others to achieve Optimal
Wellness as well and here's the best
part while helping people with their
health and wellness you'll also be able
to build your very own home-based
business
for more information contact your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about the home-based business
opportunity
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel Wallach helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-44-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call right now and leave
your name telephone number or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number
313-444-3463 that's
313-444-3463 call now to change your
life that's 313-444-3463
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the zbs radio network Dr Joel Wallach
here for young Judy manufacturers fade
and let's see here
um Doug we only have a few moments here
do we have another caller yeah let's
head to Texas and Barbara you're on with
Dr Wallach
hello Barbara are you on the air happy
to help you
I have I'm 83 years old and I have pain
on both sides of my arms which makes it
really difficult to sleep then it's kind
of getting into my back and then I have
balance problems and I thought I was
doing all the right things but I heard
Charmaine tell a previous caller that
peanuts are not good would it cost me
that much trouble I eat peanuts natural
peanut butter every day
okay well peanut butter can have a toxin
it called amplitoxin because peanuts
grow in the ground and
um they uh the sample of toxin causes
cancer it's an inflammatory thing
and peanut butter is not one of my first
choices okay uh and let's see here how
much do you weigh Barbara
150 pounds
oh kid do you have any other issues have
a pressure diabetes
I know
okay do you have any rings in your ears
any tinnitus right in your ears
oh no
okay how many times a night do you wake
up to urinate once three times five
times
probably and probably three
okay
um do you have any balance problems any
dizziness vertigo balance do you have to
use a walker
um I do have balance problems I use the
cane and it's kind of with this other
problems that's making me very anxious
so I probably
yes definitely balance problems okay
Charmaine what's going on here we only
have a moment to remain so what do we
need to do for Barbara what's her
problem she's got osteoporosis of this
call no question about it
okay so what are you gonna do for her
she's 150 pounds
um again get around the diet no no glue
healthy brain and heart packs and I
would add the collagen peptides
I would add the synaptive the vitamin D3
for absorption MSM and ultimate daily
classic for bug flow issues
and um that should take care of a good
chance
right he's uh yeah a scoop with her
morning drinking school they're eating
drink that'll take two canisters how
many eggs a day should she be eating
I would say
four to six a day minimum
yeah I'd go with six she needs um three
twice a day
um soft scramble and butter
and um
excuse me and it needs to get rid of all
the bad stuff as you said no we'd run
around oats no buckwheats uh no peanuts
all that's got to go and
um even her age she's going to see and
benefit very quickly this is a very
common problem and people forget
to when the skull gets thicker it begins
to pinch one or more of the 12 cranial
nerves begins to pinch the spinal cord
and that's why she's getting up three
times an IDE urinate the skull squeezing
the spinal cord the spinal cord is
telling the urinary bladder to urinate
and that's that's why I asked that
question it's very common
which is a steady signal red warning
light that you have osteoporosis of the
skull when you have to get up more than
once a night to urinate I get people
they have to urinate five times ten
times a night I give people say I
urinate twice an hour at night okay and
so that could be 10 12 15 times okay and
so that's because the skull is squeezing
the spinal cord telling spinal spelling
urinary bladder to urinate and this is
all totally reversible but you got to
rebuild the skull you gotta stay away
from all the bad stuff to maximize
absorption and take all the bad stuff
you can't just quote eat well unquote
and get everything you need
that's impossible and so it's one of
those things where
um you do everything right you'll be
blessed if you just sort of throw your
hands up in the air and say I I can't
change I got to keep eating the way I'm
eating I gotta keep doing what I'm doing
well then you're not going to see any
progress this is not something that a
surgery can help uh that Pharmaceuticals
can help this is a a nutritional
deficiency
it can cause as many as 37 different
diseases when you actually approach to
the skull see just in the spinal cord
alone
is 17 17
different diseases which are caused by
the skull squeezing the spinal cord
and we'll be back another day God bless
each and every one of you God bless our
troops God bless thank you so much
Jermaine thank you Doug supportive job
as usual God bless again America
[Music]